j'ai besoin de mon ordinateur tout le
temps mais bah j'ai pas d'horaire je me
connecte là où je peux sans forcément
faire attention et parfois du coup c'est
un peu le désordre alors je me suis dit
ça suffit ma
solution c'est nor VPN ah non ça c'est
un yaourt c'est juste que j'ai pas
bouffé ça rien à voir nor VPN vous
propose une protection totale pour
sécuriser votre connexion une protection
antimmenace qui reste active même quand
la connexion VPN ne l'est pas avec ses
thermorégulateur aux protéines
naturelles d'hibiscus des bois je sens
qu'il me protège du fishing et des
trackers web je sens qu'il garantit ma
sécurité
toujours ça fait combien de temps qu'on
non VPN propose trois types d'abonnement
le basique qui permet de chiffrer ses
données ou de changer l'adresse IP pour
par exemple ne pas avoir de pub sur
Youtube depuis une IP en Albanie
l'abonnement essentiel avec en plus la
protection antimmenace qui analyse les
fichiers que vous téléchargez et détecte
les applications en risque et
l'abonnement ultime qui ajoute norp et
norlcker et du coup grâce à norvpn je me
sens protégé en toute sécurité et je
peux continuer à être moi-même et à
faire ce qui me
plaît merci norvpn télécharger norvpn et
utiliser jusqu'à 10 appareils en
simultané profitez de 4 mois
d'abonnement supplémentaires gratuit sur
les abonnements de 2 ans satisfait ou
remboursé offre uniquement valable via
le lien en description
[Musique]
bon c'est la première réunion de l'année
donc c'est le moment où on définit les
grandes orientations tout ça alors moi
déjà premier sujet j'ai le maire de
Métropolis qui est venu me taper sur la
margoulette parce que soi-disant il y a
trop de destruction excusez-moi je suis
en retard désolé excusez-moi qui
êtes-vousah comment ça qui je suis bah
je suis Aquaman le roi des océans
qui aquan B je fais partie de la Justice
League Aquaman l'homme e quoi vous vous
transformez en eau ben non bah je je
lâche très très vite ok ok alors bon
c'està dire que c'est quelque chose d'un
petit peu sérieux ici he quand même bah
je peux parler au poissons et et puis ça
ça c'est de la gnnotte peut-être oui
c'est très bien ça mais bon c'està dire
qu'on a quand même l'homme d'acier
invincible he la reine des Amazones
l'homme le plus rapide du
monde c'est moi qui paye la tour et on
t'en remerciera jamais assez Batman pour
ça tu peux me croire et vous euh je suis
quand même le roi de l'Atlantique bordel
oui ben écoutez ça va et puis de toute
façon la table est déjà
[Musique]
complète alors je pense que ça serait
pas mal si on améliorait notre
communication parce que bon le dernier
sauvetage il y a quand même eu 250 morts
excusez-moi c'est pas jojo hein on va
dire les choses comme elles sont et puis
après c'est pas vous qui avvez une super
oui et qui entendit les gens chouiner
dans leur lit toute la nuit hein des
idées mais attends mais c'est toi qui a
détruit le building mais vous êtes
encore là vous des innocents sont morts
par ta faute oui bon ben ça va hein on a
détruit le building on d'accord on est
une équipe hein Justice League il y a
marqué Justice League League ouis on
pourrait faire un Twitter ou un truc
comme ça les réseaux sociaux sont des
failles de sécurité chaque twet est une
information potentiellement exploitable
une porte ouverte pour l'ennemi nous
devons accepter notre fardeau est
l'endossé nous sommes le seul bouclier
rempart de l'humanité contre les
ténèbres peu importe ce que pense le
peuple même si nous déteste notre devoir
et de le protéger non mais ça ça va
Batman vous avez pris des congés
récemment vous voulez qu'on fasse une
pause non mais Batman il a raison enfin
là arrêtez de vous chamailler j'avais
pensé qu' non mais regardez sinon on
peut faire des TikTok je fais déjà
décoré
oui oui oui alors c'est vrai que
làdessus je vibre un petit peu vite
c'est vrai oui à propos des Coré je me
disais qu'on pourrait pourz faire un
live au tuub ça marche très bien et puis
j'ai un peu de dauphin plôt mignon hein
tout le monde aime les dofins sinon on
pourrait bon quelqu une vraie idée
sérieuse là parce que je peux pas tout
entendre à la fois moi enfin si en vrai
je peux entendre tout à la fois mais
vous comprenez silence mortel je suis
Wonder Woman DS de la guerre fille de
Zeus héritière de Temis Kira quand je
parle vous vous taisez
comment vous faites pour le truc de la
musique
[Musique]
là 1 2 3
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
4 le genre de jeux qu'on a le plus fait
sur cette chaîne ce sont les jeux tirés
de comics pourquoi je l'ai déjà dit mais
je vais le répéter parce que c'est le
concept idéal le jeu est déjà tout fait
hein vous avez un super héros donc ça
plaît au petit garçon il a des super
pouvoir donc c'est pratique pour le
gameplay il y a des super vilains pour
faire des boss les costumes existent
déjà du coup il y a pas besoin de créer
des design et les enfants vont forcément
acheter puisque entre les jouets les
dessins animés et les comics bah le jeu
se vend tout seul donc bah vraiment je
pense que sur le papier il y a pas plus
facile que de faire un jeu tiré de
comics de merde ta mère la
mer tu CR dans la porte espèce de
B et pourtant des merdes il y en a eu un
paquetin alors pourquoi ben peut-être
parce que le jeu il allait se vendre
tout seul justement et donc il y avait
pas spécialement besoin de faire des
efforts et en plus de ça la licence a dû
coûter un paquet d'argent et comment
est-ce que ça a commencé et ben ça va
peut-être pas vous surprendre mais le
tout premier jeu de super-héros c'est
évidemment un jeu Superman sorti en 1979
sur Atari 2600 le jeu vous fait jouer
Superman qui doit réparer un pont
détruit par l'ex lutor alors bon
évidemment c'est très archaïque mais il
y a déjà des bases par exemple vous vous
baladez librement dans Metropolis vous
pouvez vous transformer en clar quin en
allant dans des cabines téléphoniques et
ça n'a été que le premier d'une longue
série de jeux Superman alors que
pourtant paradoxalement à ce que j'ai
dit il y a 2 minutes bah faire un jeu
Superman en vrai c'est un peu une idée
de merde je veux dire Batman c'est cool
parce que Batman il est humain il a des
faiblesses qu'il compense en sachant se
battre en utilisant des gadgets mais
Superman bah il est invincible il vole
il est immortel nexiste pas au cas où he
si il existe et du coup tu fais un jeu
comment avec ça ça va obligatoirement
être frustrant et pourtant Dieu
sait qu'ils ont essayé commodor 64 ZX
Spectrum Amiga arcade NES mais il y en a
un en particulier qui a attiré notre
attention il s'agit de Superman The Man
of Steel dans sa version Master System
sortie exclusivement en Europe en 93 le
jeu est un portage d'un jeu du même nom
sorti un an avant sur megga driive mais
qui n'est en fait rien d'autre que la
version européenne d'un jeu sorti aux
États-Unis sous le nom de Superman et
édité par Sunsoft les mêmes qui étaient
à l'origine des excellents jeux Batman
sur nest Game Boy et megga driive le
portage Master System quant à lui et
l'œeuvre du développeur britannique
craft gold pour l'éditeur Virgin
Interactive qui sortait le fantastique
Aladin au même moment sur megga drive le
jeu commence par le journal qui nous dit
que Metropolis est attaqué très bonne
illustration de cette attaque he
d'ailleurs monsieur vous êtes dans le
cadre là j'ai vu une caméra j'ai cru que
c'était pour moi et bien sûr vu l'époque
du jeu vous vous doutez qu'il va s'agir
d'un plateformeur archiassique on avance
et on tue des trucs petite originalité
cela dit on peut voler et même bon si
les contrôles font ressembler Superman à
une mouche qui rebondit sur la vitre de
la cuisine au moins c'est assez cool
pour être mentionné donc l'idée de ce
genre de jeu ça va être juste d'aller
jusqu'à la fin des niveaux alors bon
évidemment on a immédiatement pensé à
voler pour tout traverser mais non il y
a des lanceurs de chiass sur le trajet
pour t'empêcher de foncer et de toute
façon il faut aussi profiter des niveaux
pour ramasser ses pouvoirs là par
exemple maintenant que j'ai ramasser un
S rouge voilà ça y est je peux tirer des
lasers
comment ça fonctionne ça oh mes yeux les
niveaux sont en général divisés en deux
parties avec une partie plateforme
suivie d'un passage avec un écran qui
scrolle et bien sûr à la fin de chaque
niveau on retrouve un petit boss connu
de l'univers de DC Comics ou de Marie
Poppins je ne sais pas bref chaque
niveau nous demandera de faire une
nouvelle mission genre sauver des
enfants
kidnappés monsieur et bien sûr ça
m'avait manqué de ne pas hurler dans
cette émission c'est un grand classique
des jeux 8 bits de cette époque c'est
c'est absurdement dur 100% il y a un
truc devant 100% double la double
dans le fionion allez j'y vais la bouche
la bouche la bouche dans la cuisine ça
rame du cul bon allez c'est bon je sais
comment ça tourne ce genre de truc donc
je vais pas m'enculer la vie je vais
tout de suite changer la difficulté
attends attends
attends j'étais en facile en facile
c'est quoi le niveau moyen je commence
direct avec un cancer du cul bon
d'ailleurs ce jeu men of stele a
également été adapté sur Game qui est
juste un portage de la version Master
System légèrement modifié et c'est ainsi
que se terminent les aventures de
Superman sur console 8 bit presque parce
que Sunsoft qui je vous le rappelle
avait édité la version originale du jeu
sur Mega driive avait encore un projet
de jeu Superman sur NES cette fois sauf
que pour d'obscur problème de licence
ils ont dû remanier le jeu pour en faire
quelque chose qui n'a plus aucun rapport
avec Superman en l'occurrence vous jouez
ce personnage que j'ai envie d'appeler
Clark kunt hein et qui peut se
transformer en un super-héros totalement
original du nom de sunman qui doit
sauver la ville de megga City des mains
d'un gros méchant Chau à l'aide de ses
super pouvoirs originaux qui consistent
à être hyper fort voler ou encore tirer
des lasers avec les yeux tu imagines
c'est comme s'il y avait genre une
version américaine de moi avec une
chemise blanche qui teste des jeux
rétrro ridicule quoi malgré cet
impressionnant nombre de modifications
le jeu n'est quand même pas sorti mais
existe sous la forme d'un prototype
intégralement jouable en émulation ainsi
qu'une version où les sprit et musi ont
été remplacés par quelque chose de plus
familier
[Musique]
après ça rien de vraiment intéressant à
se mettre sous la dent avec Superman
pendant des années et bon après il y a
Superman 64 mais on l'a déjà
[Rires]
faitin on l'a fait
[Musique]
hein
pas n pas
suff pourô bon
euh alors apparemment on m'informe que
euh après le passage avec les anneaux
dans Superman 64 soit-disant il y aurait
un jeu et que si tu grattes la première
couche de vernis de caca et bien dessous
il y a une autre couche de caca plus dur
plus pur vous savez comme un espèce de
de de di arrête de gagner du temps alors
je ne vais pas vraiment redéblatérer sur
la partie avec les
anneau les phases où tu dois sauver des
voitures les moments où tu te coinces
dans les murs la maniabilité de merde ta
grosse conne
de ah vous imaginez ça doit être
trop cool de voir Superman en vrai
regarde papa c'est
Superman à la place on va plutôt parler
de la suite du jeu qu'on n pas montré
dans la vidéo précédente alors pourquoi
est-ce qu'on l'a pas
montré et bien il se trouve que le jeu
était incrusté dans la vidéo JDG avec
une compilation d'autres jeux de comics
notamment le jeu Batman Forever sur
megga driive et que B c'était pas
forcément pertinent d'aller plus loin
bon d'autant plus que ça aurait rallongé
la vidéo et étiré la blague pour pas
grandchose alors que bah 20 minutes ça
suffit largement vous savez le rythme
c'est quelque chose qui est vachement
important sur Youtube j'ai trouvé
la femme
ouais donc après le premier passage
d'anneau on a un nouveau type de
gameplay qui ce coupci se passe à
pied en quatre
notes oui bref c'est cet endroit vous
cononnaissez et c'est vraiment à partir
de là que le jeu commence je je
n'exagère pas tout ce qu'il y a avant
c'est la crèche ça n'existe pas à partir
de là ça devient le charnier du fun et
je le redis encore et mais le problème
de base avec les jeux Superman et encore
plus avec ce jeu c'est que je ne suis
pas Superman là le moindre truc me met
au tapis je suis misérable c'est atroce
ah fait
mal
[Musique]
ah dans ces nouveaux types de niveau on
aura donc différents objectifs qui
peuvent être sauver des gens casser des
trucs trouver des bombes activer des
interrupteurs et cetera avec de temps en
temps des combats de boss contre des
ennemis tirés de la série
[Musique]
Superman mais évidemment comme pour les
anneaux l'ennemi numéro uno c'est la
maniabilité juste se déplacer en ligne
droite te donne envie de chier des
cactus ça devrait pas être dur dans un
jeu d'avancer en ligne
droite et en plus la caméra qui prend un
rail de coque toutes les de minutes
vraiment c'est la fête des connards le
jeu te donne des pouvoirs qui sont
inutilisables à cause des contrôles de
la
manette mais pareil ce niveau je l'avais
déjà fait et du coup je réussis à le
passer dans la souffrance certes mais
j'y arrive quand
[Musique]
même je je suis mort pendant l'écran de
fin du
niveau je suis mort pendant
l'écran mer Seb bah j'ai rien
fait
par et nous voilà arrivés dans la partie
du jeu dont on n pas encore parlé je ne
vais pas le dire à chaque fois mais le
jeu entier est alterné entre phase
d'anneau et mission au sol ce qui veut
dire que chaque niveau que je vais vous
montrer maintenant dans ce test comporte
d'abord cette phase de préliminaire vous
vous faites cracher dans la bouche le
niveau suivant donc se passe dans les
bureaux de l'excp l'ex lutor qui nous a
a préparé des petites énigmes dont il a
le secret pour tester Superman hein
comme par exemple appuyer sur des
boutons dans un certain ordre dont la
réponse traîne sur un bout de papier sur
une table dans l'entrée du
bureau je suis un
véritable
Gény et sérieux c'est pas possible de
mettre aussi peu d'effort dans un projet
luutor on l'a retrouvé regardez c'est
lui ça un jpeg dégueulasse en 2D mal
détouré sous Paint là c'est la honte
mais rien ne marche rien regardez
ce bonus je peux pas l'attraper alors
que je suis devant h làas cet escalier
je peux pas le monter je suis obligé de
voler regardez la gueule de méopolis à
travers la FEN mais qu'est-ce que c'est
que ça même pas ils ont fait l'effort de
mettre l'image en couleur et ça rame
ça j'en parle pas mais la console
elle est à genoux alors que le jeu il
est moche à en chier par la bouche yes
que c'est que ça et la caméra je
je sais que c'est un problème récurrent
dans les JDG je sais qu'on parle tout le
temps de cette de caméra mais
c'est la fête à la saucisse regardez oh
bon euh j'ai besoin d'une pause
[Musique]
ok flash tu t'occupes du flanc gauche
j'ai appelé grille lanterne pour qu'il
s'occupe de ses vaisseaux dans le ciel
oh maudit so les légions de Brac
progressent craignez le courou des
Amazones et queus me chati si je faiblis
pour dis-moi elle vole notre version de
wonderoman
ou
non bon il y a Batman qui va arriver tu
fais comme si tu l'avais pas entendu
comme d'habitude ouais comme d' ouais
les ennemis avancent il nous faut un
meilleur plan oh wou oh Batman tu es là
comment tu fais ça vous mavez entendu
arriver c'est ça non non non non pas du
tout non non il y a du bordel dans le C
il y a des vaisseaux spati partout non
non rien du tout bon c'est quoi le plan
attendez je dois voir ce qu'il
faut ça c'est un spray pour tuer flash
quoi des suppositoires anti Wonder
Woman ça c'est des croquettes empoisonné
pour crypto alors kryptonite verte
[Musique]
Crypton
rouge
ja en fait j'ai
rien il faut prir
[Musique]
pourord la journéeam T travail
Superman trop puissant mais j'ai appelé
Dufor
Zana pass un chapeau qui fait de la
magie je comends plus est
méchante
anim c'est et le
gronz c'est rendez-vous AC dans 20
minutes alors sal
allez bonne
journée je suis là brgac va connaître la
défaite grâce à mes
flèches
attendez c'est
fini d'ailleurs un autre truc à la con
qui montre la flemme ou les problèmes
j'en sais rien pendant la création de ce
jeu quand tu meurs au sol Superman
s'effondre au sol bon ok mais si tu
meurs en en vol bah tu te contentes de
rester planté là comme ça regarde fils
c'est Superman le protecteur de
[Musique]
Métropolis mais allez on finit le niveau
et Superman s'en va vers le niveau
suivant et n'oubliez pas les enfants
soyez sages et respecter vos
voisins ah oui j'ai pas précisé parce
que bon dans ma tête ça me semble
évident mais il y a
évidemment aucun respect de l'univers
des comics hein catapulter leur mort
allez-y vraiment cette suite de jeu ne
nous épargne aucune souffrance c'est la
checklist de Satan il y a la quête où il
faut mettre des caisses sur des
interrupteur du backtracking constant
absolument à vomir à cause de la
maniabilité le level design qui n'a
évidemment aucun sens genre ouais bon le
mec qui bosse ici ça doit être chiant
pour lui quoi je vais prendre ma pause
[Musique]
un déc s'il vous plaît et bien sûr bien
sûr bien sû les
inévitablbles quêtes d'escorte de PN qui
avance à de à l'heure
évidemment voilà
voilà où z que le métro de Metropolis a
été fondé en
1915 par Tom Walter et Herbert Whitfield
les
fondate je suis Superman je pourrais le
soulever m'envoler à travers le métro
passer à travers le plafond finir ça en
une
seconde pourquoi tu me fais ça des fois
dans ces quêtes c'est l'unire des fois
le jeu essaie de te mettre la pression
comme ça pour rien il a genre il y a un
timer qui apparaît d'un seul coup et
puis le timer il arrive à zéro et puis
il se passe
rien le jeu il a aucune autorité on
dirait vous savez les parents qui font
attention hein à 3 celle-là va partir
hein alors 1
2 attention hein oh là là la caméra qui
arrive pas à faire son traveling pendant
la cinématique de victoire mais au
secours ah mais je vous jure tu as envie
de lui jeter des pièces au jeu allez
niveau suivant il faut retrouver dark
side dans un parking benah quoi vous
connaissez pas l'univers de Superman et
bien ici une fois encore après un
million de quêtes chiantes du genre
péter toutes les voitures pour aucune
de raison que je ne vous détaille
pas on gelle de bombes que Dark Side a
posé mais attention il va revenir se
venger ah la revanche de Dark Side dans
le parking meilleure série de comics
mais dites-moi êtes-vous comme moi hein
avez-vous aimé la Snider cut de la
Justice League et du coup peut-être que
vous regrettez de ne jamais pouvoir voir
le combat final entre Dark Side et
Superman et bien le jeu exauce votre
souhait donc on bat dark side en
l'humiliant comme une mais alors
vraiment il y a aucun moyen de perdre un
combat de boss tellement c'est facile
regardez ça je t'attendais superm oh
ça fait mal je joue avec son
cadavre honnêtement c'est le seul moment
du jeu où on s'amusait et c'est ainsi
que vous battez l'ennemi le plus
puissant de l'univers de DC Comics
jonglant avec son cul allez hop
direction
Narnia mais c'est pas fini parce que le
jeu il veut pas te laisser partir non il
faut ensuite ramener le corps de Dark
Side à la police en se tapant tout le
chemin en sens inverse en portant le
corps de Dark Side en marchant le plus
lentement possible et je dis ça souvent
je sais mais c'est peut-être des trucs
les plus buggés que j'ai vu en 15 ans de
JDG le corps de Dark sideide glitch
absolument
partout mais
jeen peux
plus c'est comme une scène post crédit
dans un film qui durerait 45 minutes
j'ai fini le jeu laissez-moi partir
libérez-nous ah méchants elfs nous ont
attaché au jeu
libérez-nous pourquoi c'est pas fini
mais pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi
pourquoi c'est pas fini j'ai battu
l'exlutor j'ai j'ai battu dark side
c'est le mec le plus puissant an de
l'univers des du qu'est-ce que je dois
faire pour avoir le droit de
partir chaque nouveau niveau c'est
l'équivalent de se mettre un oursin dans
le cul et et et en parlant d'oursin
niveau suivant il y a de l'eau qui
ralentit tes mouvements je jouais déjà à
H images par
seconde merde mais ça y est après le
niveau de métro on a enfin le dernier
niveau de ce jeu et ah
ah ils ont remis le Banger de l'ost ah
ils ont dû se dire que les gens sur
cette musique ils étaient en mode encore
encore encore et ce dernier niveau
c'est à la fois triste et drôle c'est
peut-être mes ner qui lâche c'est
tellement mauvais et les objectifs n'ont
tellement plus aucun sens que les
développeurs ont mis des grosses flèches
rouges sur le sol pour t'indiquer ce
qu'il faut faire parce que moi j'ai
j'arrête pas de dire que j'en ai marre
mais peut-être que le jeu il en a marre
aussi hein peut-être que le jeu aussi il
passe un mauvais moment on sait pas et
même avec ça le niveau c'est à étaler sa
merde sur les murs tout se ressemble tu
es tout le temps perdu évidemment en
plus on est au sommet de la montagne du
bug vous savez c'est vraiment le myth
d'Icar où plus tu approches du soleil
plus tu te fais pissé dans la gorge par
un gang de camionneurs bourrés qui
sortent d'une soirée raclette aux
asperges is après je suis pas super fort
en mythologie grec non plus dans ce
dernier niveau il faut récupérer des
pièces pour reconstituer je sais pas
quoi afin de battre bregnac combien de
pièces à
récupérer
11 11 pièces à ramasser en errrance en
repère dans cette usine à merde je sais
même pas mettre des mot dessus entre les
objets sur lesquels il faut cliquer qui
ressembl à d'autres objets sur lesquels
tu ne peux pas cliquer les règles mais
qui n'ont aucun sens du du genre pour
faire fonctionner un portail de
téléportation il faut d'abord lui
envoyer un tonneau d'explosif dessus et
les trucs impossibles à comprendre c'est
quoi ces chiffres pourquoi il y a des
chiffres sur mon
écraning je sais pas évidemment faut la
quête d'escorte finale le cafard sur le
gâteau le poil de cul sur la brosse à
dents ah toi aussi tu as l' lunch dans
ce dernier passage il faut emmener lois
et Jimmy pour leur faire traverser une
salle remplie d'éclair et pour ça est-ce
que je les porte et je leur fais
traverser la salle à toute
vitesse mais bien sûr que non on va
plutôt faire du curling avec loï et
Jimmy bah voilà on va les transformer en
bloc de glace et on va les pousser parce
que faire une quête d'escorte avec un
perso qui bouge lentement mais tout le
monde peut le faire il faut en faire une
avec un perso qui ne bouge c'est du
génie vous saviez à quel point je
déteste les enfants ta gueule de conne
papa il veut dormir il n a pas de mot
dans le langage des hommes des orques ou
des elfes pour décrire à quel point tout
cela pue la merde mais après plusieurs
heures d'essès sur ce dernier niveau
nous y voilà le jeu est terminé et avant
de vous montrer la cinématique de fa
donnez-moi juste une petite seconde
[Musique]
bien joué vous avez réussi à sortir vos
amis de ce
cauchemar on parle toujours du jeu là et
voilà la fin voilà devant vous la fin du
jeu Superman 64 un caméraman
qui je sais pas ce qu'il fait je ne
comprends pas ce que fait cette caméra
et de là je m'en
fous je veux crever
bref je pense que c'est
le pire jeu du monde vraiment je pense
que c'est le pire jeu pire que Bubsy 3D
dans Bubsy bah le jeu est vide il y a
une voix de merde il y a pas de texture
mais bah c'est finissable et c'est pire
que Dragon slir parce que dans Dragon
slir au moins il y a pas la caméra de
merde qui fait n'importe quoi il y a pas
les trucs absurdes et incompréhensibles
non non c'est c'est vraiment le pire jeu
de tous les temps Superman 64 la moitié
du jeu c'est de se faire chier à voler à
travers des anneaux et l'autre moitié du
jeu c'est d'espérer vite finir le niveau
pour retourner se faire chier à voler à
travers des anneaux et attendez parce
que bon là on a fini de bouffer certe un
petit café il y a un mode multioueur je
n'avais jamais entendu parler de ce mode
multioueur vraiment je n'ai vu personne
en parler sur le net personne et ben il
y a peut-être une raison donc ce mode
multijoueur a deux modes de jeu jusqu'à
4 qui nous permett de nous affronter
dans Metropolis bienvenue à
mettropolis la ville du futur tu veux
jouer à Superman 64 Seb allez tu veux
jouer qui Superman ah non désolé il y a
pas et effectivement je ne plaisante pas
regarder les personnages il n'y est pas
je vais redire ça lentement mais vous ne
pouvez pas jouer Superman dans le
multijoueur du jeu Superman on est à
quel degré de maladie mentale alors le
premier mode c'est juste un Death Match
de merde dans des arènes trop grandes
mais dans le deuxième mode ils ont
réussi à avoir la pire idée possible
puisque le but du jeu est qu'un des deux
joueurs chie des anneaux en boucle
pendant que l'autre doit passer dedans
pourquoi pourquoi j'irais demander à des
gens que je suis censé apprécier de
subir ça avec moi en même temps la
portie avec les anneaux c'est la
meilleure partie du jeu
hein étrangement ton argument fonctionne
et et le pire vous savez c'est que une
bonne version de ce jeu Superman 64 a
failli exister hein c'est la version
PlayStation qui est jouable seulement en
émulation toujours édité par Titus elle
est au final beaucoup plus aboutie il y
a des meilleurs idées de gameplay par
exemple refroidir les portes ou les
réchauffer il y a pas besoin de
récupérer ses pouvoirs on les a déjà
tous dès le début il y a des costumes
différents et cetera et bah elle est
jamais sortie le jeu qui est jouable sur
Internet puisqu'il est fini à plus de 90
% a été annulé par Warner Bros suite à
une série de différents avec l'éditeur
Titus coulant au passage le développeur
du jeu Sky software connu pour par
exemple le Jurassic Park de la Mega
Drive alors qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
avec ce jeu comment est-ce qu'on peut
foirer un truc à ce point-là est-ce que
les développeurs ont pris de la drogue
euh non mais par contre chez warder Bros
c'est moins sûr Superman 64 c'est le
résultat d'une collaboration
catastrophique entre Warner les
détenteurs de la licence DC Comics et
Titus l'éditeur du jeu sauf que très
rapidement Titus s rendu compte que les
gens de chez Warner les détestaient et
qu'ils essayaient de saboter le jeu à
toutes les étapes du développement en
faisant des demandes débiles comme par
exemple alors oui on aimerait faire un
jeu Superman où Superman serait en fait
le maire de Metropolis et il pourrait
par exemple inaugurer des bibliothèques
et puis vous connaissez Sim City ils ont
enchaîné juste pour leur casser les
couilles alors il faudrait sauver une
princesse et puis il pourrait prendre
des champignons pour grandir et est-ce
que vous connaissez Sonic et du coup à
chaque fois Titus refusé ce qui énervait
encore plus le Honner Bros qui pour se
venger sabotter encore plus le projet et
cetera et CETA et par exemple les
niveaux sous l'eau avaient à la base été
refusé par Warner qui disait que
Superman il irait jamais sous l'eau what
the fuck ils ont pété les plombs Titus
ou quoi et donc pour faire accepter les
niveaux aquatiques à Warner Bros il a
fallu que les mecs de chez Titus
éplugent des centaines de comics en leur
montrant que si regarder numéro 348 page
12 Superman il va sous l'eau attendez il
y a des comics
Superman et tout ça ça fait perdre du
temps et ça explique pas mal de choses
du jeu par exemple les niveau avec les
anneaux c'était censé être uniquement le
tuto et rien de plus et ça a du sens et
pareil alors je ne vous l'ai pas redit
parce que j'en parle dans la première
vidéo sur Superman 64 mais je vous le
rappelle quand même le jeu se passe dans
un univers virtuel un virtuel Metropolis
ne chercheis pas ben c'est parce que
Warner Bros ne voulait pas que Superman
puisse blesser de vrais gens et donc il
a fallu maroufler le scénario et en plus
si tu ajoutes à ça que forcément les
mecs de chez Warner mettaient des
semaines à répondre à la moindre demande
et bien à la fin du développement il
n'est plus resté assez de temps pour
corriger les bugs et ça a donné ça
Warner Bros devra attendre 2006 pour
avoir son jeu Superman avec Superman
Returns adapté du film du même nom et le
jeu est pas super bien noté alors que
franchement ça va par exemple une idée
cool du jeu c'est que vous n'avez pas de
barre de vie bah oui Superman est
invincible logique donc bah votre barre
de vie c'est la barre de santé de
mtropolis et plus les ennemis vont
le SB blesser des civils détruire
des immeubles et cetera plus cette barre
va descendre avec comme possibilité de
la faire remonter en sauvant les civils
blessés dans nos combats en les
transportant temps jusqu'à une ambulance
d'une façon un peu étrange
j'avoue vous avez mal c'est votre jambe
c'est ça et ben ça c'est une vraie idée
cool jusqu'à un certain point parce que
Ben comme forcément les ennemis ne
peuvent pas vous tuer vu que vous avez
pas de barre de vie il faut quand même
trouver un moyen de donner du challenge
et donc ben le jeu va systématiquement
faire courir des civiles devant votre
nez pendant les bastons jusqu'à un point
où ça devient un peu ridicule c'est
l'espace public ici ça appartient à tout
le monde je passe si je veux hein et
pourtant même avec ce petit problème
c'est ça qu'on veut on se déplace à
toute vitesse dans Metropolis les
missions secondaires sont cool il y a
des ennemis qui sont démesurés à la
hauteur d'un Superman pendant les
bagarres on voit les civils paniquer
s'enfuir les voitures exploser à cause
de nos actions c'est cool moi je suis
juste content qu'ils aient compris le
personnage de Superman bref ben j'aime
bien ce jeu et tout va très
très oh
non ils
arrivri bon heureusement ça va c'est
juste un tout petit passage une vraie
critique cependant de ce jeu c'est
l'absence quasi totale de cutsin qui
rend le rythme du jeu un peu trop
intense on enchaîne quasiment sans pause
les robots géants les chute de météorit
les invasions extraterrestres les
sauvetages de fin du monde le tout sans
absolument aucune histoire et bon ça
devient un peu ridicule au B moment
surtout quand le jeu revient ensuite à
l'histoire principale avec l'ex lutor
qui elle suit l'intrigue du film et qui
est en mode je suis le plus grand vilain
de tous les temps alors que bon je viens
de tuer un robot de métal géant il y a 3
secondes quoi et du coup je comprends
pas que ça soit mal noté B après
peut-être que quand on a vu ce que nous
on a
vu explosion et surtout il y a pas eu
d'autres jeux Superman depuis c'était
celui-là le dernier mais c'était il y a
18 ans alors il y a eu des jeux de
baston avec Superman certes il est
apparu comme personnage ailleurs mais
bah il y a pas eu d'autres jeux à lui il
y a bien eu des rumeurs d'un jeu
Superman il y a quelques années fait par
rock steadyy he suite au succès de la
série des jeux de Batman Arkham mais le
jeu ne se fera pas et au final le projet
se transformera en suicide Squad kill de
Justice League pourquoi et ben peut-être
pour les raisons qu'on disait au début
de cette vidéo faire un jeu Superman
satisfaisant et en même temps avec du
challenge et ben c'est comp après bon
c'est vrai qu'il y a pas de super bon
jeu mais il y a de très bonnes
[Musique]
séries voilà la bataille s plutôt bien
passé au final moins de destruction
moins de mort je vous ai dit de plus
jamais faire ça mais j'ai rien fait je
suis resté ici toute la journée vu que
la bataille se déroulait pas sous l'eau
je vous prle pas vous vous taisezvous tu
les guideras dans l'obscuritéel ils te
suivront comme un oui ça ça va c'est bon
déjà écoué le livre audio ça va hein et
puis vous êtes pas censé être à la
Forteresse de Solitude vous mais
c'est-à-dire que personne n'y a jamais
mis les pieds dans votre garçonnière là
si moi quoi j'ai j'ai j'ai dit j'ai dit
que tu dois guider les humains à travers
les difficultés pause pause pause 2
secondes 2 secondes comment ça vous êtes
déjà allé à ma forteresse de solitude
alors comme ça vous invitez Batman et
pas moi alors que je suis votre cousine
ma cousine j'ai une cousine
moi attendez on peut quand même revenir
de secondes
sur tu viens manger
[Musique]
dimanche alors le prochain c'est un
monsieur de
Métropolis bon je vous écoute bon voilà
moi j'habite au centrre-ville de
Métropolis et ça chicane tous les jours
là-bas hein entre Luthor bregnac et
compagnie je peux vous dire qu'on
s'ennuie pas oui oui oui ouioui alors
bah moi je faisais des livraisons je
livre des agrafes avec mon camion je
sors les cartons je sonne à la porte le
temps qu'on vient de m'ouvrir je me
retourne et là pof il y a plus de camion
alors je lève la tête et qu'est-ce que
je vois mon camion il est dans les
grosses miches de métalau mais je leur
dis quoi mes clients moi qu'ils iront
chercher leurs agrafes dans le derch à
métalau et ben je sais pas moi vous avez
qu'à leur dire que que votre camion il a
contribué à sauver la ville oui bah
sauver la ville sauver la ville mais en
attendant mes clients ils auront pas
leurs agraphes et comment ils font s'ils
ont pas leurs agrapes hein ils attachent
leurs feuilles comment oh c'est terrible
alors bonjour je suis désolé en fait je
suis pêcheur et vous avez comment dire
gelé le lac et vous l'avez transporté
comment dire jusquen Californie et il se
trouve que bah c'est très c'est très
joli très impressionnant me faites pas
dire ce que j'ai pas dit mais mais comme
je suis pêcheur ben j'ai plus de boulot
parce qu'il y a plus de poisson bah oui
parce qu'il y a plus d'eau parce qu'il y
a plus de lac quoi mais c'est toi qui a
tué tous ces poissons cétait dark
sideide ah bah oui dark sideide oui dark
sideide il veut conquérir l'univers et
tu crois qu'il en a quelque chose à
de tes poissons alors je voulais
pas vous embêter je tenais juste à vous
le signaler ah mais c'est pour ça qu'il
y a plus de poisson à la cantine après
aucune pression juste j'aimerais vous
dire que vous êtes mon dernier espoir
avant que je me fout en l'air mais à
part ça tout va bien ok attendez de quoi
on parlerit vous voulez du poisson vous
c'est ça non mais vous savez quoi vous
embêtez pas je vois que je dérange je
veux pas vous embêter plus longtemps je
vais prendre mon camtar et je vais me
à la flotte dans la rivière comme
ça on en parle plus ah je sais pas
a pas moyen que REM de l'eau dans votre
lac là ah non ah non je fais pas ça moi
tout ce qui est au dou je touche pas moi
je trouve que l' dou c'est pour les
[Musique]
cons écoutez vous vous avez un camion
mais vous avez plus de travail parce
qu'il y a plus de poisson d'accord oui
tout à fait et vous là vous avez besoin
d'un camion pour V livraison c'est ça
c'est bien ça ouais alors vous allez
faire quoi
bah c'està- direire que ça m'embête un
peu parce que j'ai pas de grand frigo
pour mettre les poissons moi ah il a
raison j'arrive pas à attacher ces
feuilles il y a pas moyen de trouver une
foutue à grave dans ce pays